>>> TURNING ON TRUMP, THE
EDITORIAL BOARDS OF TWO
NEWSPAPERS NOW BOTH OF THEM
OWNED BY FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
MEDIA ALLY RUPERT MURDOCH ARE
CONDEMNING THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FOR HIS INACTION ON JANUARY 6th.
THE NEW YORK POST EDITORIAL
BOARD'S HEADLINE READING TRUMP'S
SILENCE ON JANUARY 6 IS DAMNING.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" READ
THE PRESIDENT WHO STOOD STILL ON
JANUARY 6th.
VICE CHAIR OF THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY 6th LIZ
CHENEY POINTING THIS OUT DURING
AN INTERVIEW ON MURDOCH-OWNED
FOX NEWS.
>> LOOK, IT'S NOT JUST ME THAT
IS SAYING THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
UNFIT FOR OFFICE, IT'S OTHER
ENTITIES OWNED BY RUPERT
MURDOCH, IT'S THE NEW YORK POST
IN THEIR EDITORIAL ON FRIDAY,
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
THE SAME THING AFTER OUR HEARING
ON THURSDAY NIGHT.
>> JOINING US NOW CNN SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST JOHN AVALON,
ANA NAVARRO AND FORMER
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN AND
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
JOE WALSH IT'S INTERESTING TO
HEAR HER SAY THAT BUT I WONDER
DO YOU THINK IT MATTERS IF FOX
NEWS ISN'T SAYING IT?
>> WELL, SHE'S SAYING IT ON FOX
NEWS SO I THINK THAT MATTERS
AND, LOOK, YOU KNOW, FIRST I --
MY ADMIRATION FOR LIZ CHENEY
JUST GROWS BY THE DAY.
THIS WOMAN WILL FOLLOW DONALD
TRUMP TO THE GATES OF HELL IF
SHE HAS TO AND SHE WILL MAKE IT
HER LIFE'S PURPOSE TO MAKE SURE
THAT HE IS NOT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AGAIN.
LOOK, I THINK PEOPLE ARE
COMING -- REPUBLICANS EVEN --
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS, TRUMP
SUPPORTING CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS ARE COMING TO THE
REALIZATION THIS MAN HAS A TON
OF BAGGAGE.
IT IS UNDENIABLE.
AND THAT HAS BEEN A FEAT AND A
TASK THAT'S BEEN ACHIEVED BY THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEES AND THERE
ARE OTHERS WHO DON'T HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF BAGGAGE.
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE NOT
GOING TO GO DOWN IN HISTORY AS
COMPLICIT IN PROMOTING AN
INSURRECTION AND A COUP AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES.
>> MY RESPECT FOR LIZ CHENEY
EQUALS THAT, BUT LIZ CHENEY IS
GOING TO LOSE IN A MONTH AND
SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO LOSE
OVERWHELMINGLY.
IF SEAN HANNITY COMES OUT AND
SAYS WHAT THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" SAID, DONALD TRUMP IS
UNFIT AND HE SHOULDN'T RUN
AGAIN, THEN I WILL PAY
ATTENTION.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" ISN'T
WHERE REPUBLICAN BASE VOTERS ARE
RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS STILL TRUMP'S PARTY.
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO SLOW
DOWN.
>> YEAH, BUT, LOOK, I THINK
PEOPLE WHO WONDERED AT THE
BEGINNING WILL THESE HEARINGS
HAVE ANY EFFECT?
ARE THERE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PERSUADABLE?
THE ANSWER IS YES AND THE FACT
THAT THE EDITORIAL BOARDS MOOD
IS AN INDICATION OF THAT.
I AGREE WITH YOU, THIS HAS
MAXIMUM IMPACT WHEN THAT JUMPS
OVER TO FOX NEWS, BUT THE FACT
THAT THE NEW YORK POST IS SAYING
HE IS UNFIT TO BE PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
THAT'S STARK LANGUAGE.
THE FACT THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WHO HAVE TESTIFIED UNDER OATH AT
THE COMMITTEE HAVE MOVED THE
BALL -- MOVED THIS BAR IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE SAYING, YOU KNOW,
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT FIT BECAUSE
HIS ACTIONS ARE THE WORST
NIGHTMARE OF THE FOUNDING
FATHERS.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
LISTEN, I LIVE IN FLORIDA AND AS
POPULAR AS RON DeSANTIS IS WITH
THE REPUBLICANS IN FLORIDA, I
THINK IF IT WAS A HEAD TO HEAD
BETWEEN RON DeSANTIS AND DONALD
TRUMP WHO BY THE WAY IS ALSO
FROM FLORIDA WHERE EVERY NUT
CASE HAS GONE TO LIVE IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS -- BUT, ANYWAYS,
I DIGRESS, I THINK IN A HEAD TO
HEAD DONALD TRUMP WOULD PROBABLY
STILL BEAT DeSANTIS EVEN THOUGH
HE IS INCREDIBLY WELL-LIKED.
>> THIS ISN'T SURPRISING.
I MEAN, REPUBLICAN INSIDERS
DON'T WANT TRUMP TO RUN, DONORS
DON'T WANT TRUMP TO RUN, MY
FORMER COLLEAGUES DON'T WANT
TRUMP TO RUN, THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" MUCH OF CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TRUMP TO RUN
BUT UNTIL VOTERS SAY THAT AND I
DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
HE'S GOING TO ANNOUNCE IN A
MONTH.
>> AND IN 2016 NONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WANTED TRUMP TO RUN,
EITHER.
>> EXACTLY.
THE DIFFERENCE S JOIS A LOT OF
DONORS DON'T SAY IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCARED.
THERE'S FEAR OF DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE OF THE BASE.
WHAT'S SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THE
EDITORIAL BOARD SPEAKING UP
CLEARLY IS THEY ARE CLEARLY NOT
SCARED.
>> WE HAVE MORE OF LIZ CHENEY
TALKING TO JAKE TAPPER.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> I'M FIGHTING HARD, NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS ON AUGUST 16 I'M
GOING TO WAKE UP ON AUGUST 17
AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT HARD TO
ENSURE DONALD TRUMP IS NEVER
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THE OVAL
OFFICE EVER AGAIN.
>> IF YOU END UP LOSING YOUR JOB
IN CONGRESS BECAUSE OF YOUR WORK
ON THIS COMMITTEE, IT WILL HAVE
BEEN WORTH IT TO YOU?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION I
BELIEVED THAT MY WORK ON THIS
COMMITTEE IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I HAVE EVER DONE
PROFESSIONALLY.
>> SO THAT'S LIZ CHENEY TALKING
ABOUT WHAT YOU WERE JUST TALKING
B JOE, THE VERY REAL POSSIBILITY
THAT SHE MIGHT LOSE IN THIS
PRIMARY IN JUST A FEW WEEKS AND
SHE MIGHT AND SHE STILL THINKS
IT'S WORTH IT.
MY QUESTION IS WHICH GETS TO
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
BEFOREHAND, DO YOU THINK DONALD
TRUMP ENTERING THE PRESIDENTIAL
RACE FREEZES THE RACE, KEEPS
OTHER CANDIDATES OUT, BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING NOW.
I MEAN, MIKE PENCE IS RUNNING,
HASN'T ANNOUNCED YET, I'M NOT
MAKING AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON BEHALF
OF MIKE PENCE BUT HE'S DOING
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT NOW.
RON DeSANTIS IS SORT OF DOING
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE OTHER REPUBLICANS
DOING THE SAME.
DOES HE FREEZE THE FIELD?
>> NOT ENTIRELY.
>> THAT'S A CHANGE.
>> IT IS A CHANGE, BUT, LOOK,
THIS HAS ALL BEEN HAPPENING IN
SLOW MOTION BUT IT'S BEEN AN
OPEN SECRET.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING I'M GOING TO
START BUILDING MY COMMITTEE BUT
HOPEFULLY DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T
GET IN.
SOME OF THEM ARE PAST THE POINT
OF NO RETURN BECAUSE THEY ARE
NEVER GOING TO GET IN GOOD
GRACES.
IF I BUILD SOMETHING AND HE
DOESN'T GET IN MAYBE I WILL GET
HIS SUPPORT.
THAT'S A FOOL'S ERRAND FROM THE
BEGINNING.
YOU WILL SEE SOME FOLKS GET IN
AND THERE IS A WHOLE BUNCH MORE
WAITING IN THE WINGS.
>> I ABSOLUTELY THINK RON
DeSANTIS GETS IN WHETHER TRUMP
RUNS OR NOT.
THERE IS A STRANGE FROSTINESS
THAT'S DEVELOPED BETWEEN THE TWO
OF THEM.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW IT PLAYS OUT DURING
DeSANTIS'S REELECTION CAMPAIGN
THIS YEAR.
I'M LOOKING TO SEE WHETHER
DONALD TRUMP COMES OUT AND SAYS
HE'S BEING DISRESPECTFUL TO YOUR
PRESIDENT.
ARE YOU GOING TO VOTE FOR A MAN
WHO HASN'T COMMITTED TO ENDORSE
YOUR PRESIDENT IF I DECIDE TO
RUN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT'S GOING
TO MEAN IN FLORIDA.
WE SAW WHAT TRUMP'S WORDS MEANT
IN GEORGIA WHEN IT CAME TO, YOU
KNOW, THOSE SENATE RACES.
SO I THINK THAT'S GOING TO PLAY
OUT.
I THINK RON DeSANTIS IS, AS YOU
SAY, FAR TOO GONE, HE'S BUILT UP
A TEAM.
IF HE WINS DECISIVELY IN FLORIDA
THIS YEAR, I THINK RON DeSANTIS
IS RUNNING REGARDLESS OF WHAT
TRUMP DOES OR DOESN'T DO.
>> CALL ME CRAZY, I THINK TRUMP
CLEARS THE FIELD.
THIS IS STILL HIS PARTY.
JOHN, YOU'RE RIGHT, EVERYBODY IS
POSITIONING THEMSELVES, BUT,
MAN, HE STILL OWNS THE VOTERS
RIGHT NOW AND ONCE HE IS OUT
THERE DOING HIS THING AND
CRITICIZING THESE PEOPLE,
IT'S -- SLOW DOWN.
SLOW DOWN.
>> MIKE PENCE, WHO IS HE
POSITIONING HIMSELF WITH?
PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE GOING TO SEE
HIM AS A COMPLICIT COWARD WHO
DID NOTHING BUT LICK TRUMP'S
BOOTS FOR FOUR YEARS AND PEOPLE
WHO LOVE TRUMP ARE GOING TO SEE
HIM AS COMPLICIT WITH WHAT THEY
SEE AS A RIGGED ELECTION.
>> IS THAT NOT AN ENDORSEMENT?
YOU DIDN'T ENDORSE MIKE PENCE,
JUST TO BE CLEAR?
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU I FIND
MIKE PENCE SAYING THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK FORWARD AND NOT LOOK
BACK, IN OTHER WORDS, MOVE ON
FROM JANUARY 6 SO OFFENSIVE
AFTER WE HEARD HIS SECRET
SERVICE CALLING THEIR FAMILIES
TO SAY GOOD-BYE ON JANUARY 6.
IF NOTHING ELSE, IF NOTHING
ELSE, HE OWES THAT DETAIL THAT
RISKED THEIR LIVES TO SAVE HIM
MUCH MORE RESPECT.
>> THERE'S NO TRUMP-PENCE SLIT
IN THE PARTY.
PENCE HAS NO CONSTITUENCY AMONG
REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
>> I THINK HIS FAMILY WILL STILL
VOTE FOR HIM.
>> PENCE HAS A BIG APPEARANCE IN
D.C. TODAY, TRUMP HAS ONE
TOMORROW, AND THEN THIS COMES ON
THE HEELS OF APPEARANCES THEY
MADE RECENTLY IN ARIZONA WHERE
THEY HAVE ENDORSED DIFFERENT
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATES AND
THERE IS A BIT OF A PROXY WAR
THAT'S PLAYING OUT.
BUT YOU SAY -- YOU SAY NO THERE
ISN'T APPARENTLY THIS IS A
ONE-SIDED WAR.
>> PENCE MAY NOT BE CHUMMY WITH
TRUMP ANYMORE BUT THERE IS NO
SPLIT IN THE PARTY.
MIKE PENCE HAS NO CONSTITUENCY
AMONG REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
NONE.